this is from the guys who directed Cyrus
Jeff who lives at home stars Jason Segel
Ed Helms Susan Sarandon and Judy Greer
you'll find in this movie as well my
favorite opening lines I've seen in a
while you guys know I'm a huge fan of
the film's signs it was kind of the film
that got me interested in directing in
general when I was younger and Jason
Segel plays this guy named Jeff
extremely inspired by the movie signs he
feels that everything happens for a
reason that fate is just intertwined
that he sees signs in real life that
will lead him to things thinks he sees
things everywhere that have some deep
meaning that will lead him into a better
life and he follows these dreams of his
he goes out right to do it ed Helmes
plays a guy who's married to Judy Greer
and their marriage is on the rocks and
he's running around trying to figure out
if she's having an affair Susan Sarandon
is the mother of these two young
brothers she's at work and the secret
admirer is sending her I am all day and
she's trying to figure out who it is and
these three stories intersect in certain
ways that have effect on all of their
lives I really enjoyed this movie this
was a very heartfelt comedy I really
felt for the characters of this movie
they seemed real even though a lot of
them were so exaggerated as people like
particularly Jeff Jason Steel's
character so different and quirky and
odd but I just felt so much for his
character it just it seemed so sweet I
mean if you can think of one word to
describe this movie it's just such a
sweet poem Jason Segel holds this movie
together in every way his performance is
so calm and understated but it works so
well for this movie and I just I loved
him in this film I thought he was so
good he was quietly hilarious really he
wasn't like in-your-face look I'm a
funny guy
he was subdued at just the right level
ed Helms has that really big grin and it
really worked for his character in this
movie because he plays kind of a you
know a little bit of a douche bag and he
does a really good job that he gives a
good performance in this movie Susan
Sarandon is also very good and has to
film jump between various stories I was
able to flow with all them well and I
felt for each of these characters and
just I just really liked the way this
film tied together the movie was really
hilarious it was there were there were
characters that seemed like they were in
real situations and they had real
arguments I really liked the fact that
the script and these actors were able to
maintain such realism and some of the
dramatic scenes now yes the directors
are known for doing this zoom in thing
really fast they zoom and not a lot of
shots they get all close to your face
and it gets a little overdone at times
it does and there are times when I was
like okay that's not necessary to keep
ten years they do that over and over
again but after a while you kind of get
the feel of it it does feel a little bit
documentary esque I really enjoyed this
film Jason Segel was excellent and it
heartfelt characters I was able to feel
for B get a chance check out Jeff lives
at home I'm gonna give it an a- and
check out my awesome new channel
background made by the brilliant artist
tin salim munich but check out his
website below that man is a genius of
art thank you for that awesome
background until next time guys if you
like this review you can subscribe to my
channel and get stuck mine eyes